good morning Millennials welcome back to
the dust and happy Monday you guys if
you hear a stunning vibrato it's because
Jackie and I are together the girls back
in town the girls are back in town
Jackson's in New York and I have one
question Jax
how you doing
I'm doing good thank you so much for
asking it's great to be back in this
incredible City incredible
um it's just so amazing I love it here
so much who would have the plot twist of
the year that you fell in love NYC that
I fell in love with New York and it's so
funny because when I lived here and
people would come visit and they would
be like New York is the best city I'd be
like how could you think that like are
you dumb you saw do you have eyes but
now I really I get it it's the city of
small doses and I'm so happy to be here
it's an amazing time to be in New York
like the lights the festivities the cold
got to wear my jacket my earmuffs I
bought a new pair of gloves from Jane
crew that let me text you know I don't
text and walk oh those texting gloves
are a real real feat of uh technology
not Perfection though like they're not
it doesn't feel like your actual thing
like yeah but it gets the job done it
does it gets the job done if you needed
to change the song change the song yeah
so it's great to be here we have a
jam-packed week planned I actually
vlogging my time here in New York
because I know everyone's like Jax what
are you getting into what's going on
everyone like I've been getting like
berated in my DM how sad for you no
they're like what's Jack's doing in New
York and you have a busy busy week they
can find out at the patreon.com the
toast later this week later this week
um it's so great to have you here I love
podcasting with you in person it's been
so long looking in your eyes it's so
weird podcasting in person now it's like
let me tell you so close together let me
tell you I'm so glad you brought that up
because like honestly in the beginning I
was like oh my God we talk about it
every time we're together we're so close
together it's like low-key weird like
you're like why are you looking at me
like that you know no why are you
looking at me stop why are you looking
at me because you're so beautiful
it's true
um speaking of beautiful Jackie and I
both got spray tans and when I tell you
I have a new lease on life like really
um what's that phrase like don't Tone It
tan it yes that is please will you
ensure that that's on my Tombstone like
it's so cheap beautiful words to live by
we need to get you a pillow that says
don't don't Tone It tan it like what I
can remember I you know it's words to
live by words to die by when I took off
my clothes to like get in the shower to
rinse it off
um usually like I take my clothes off
and like I Sprint past the mirror like
I'm not interested in seeing what my
naked body looks like it's it's honestly
traumatizing but when I tell you I
didn't like you know stop and stare but
I I ran a little slower I was like oh
who is she that bronze Beauty wow but
then it's like seeing like the Milky
color of like your bare ass like that
will make you want to kill yourself like
you will don't turn around too don't
turn around why don't you use the thong
and tan your ass
um I usually do wear the paper thong I
didn't because I have my period so I
just like you asked so
you asked and yes I do have my period so
months from now when you're watching my
comedy special that I am recording
tonight and tomorrow night just know
that's a girl with her period And if she
can do that you can do anything actually
everyone has does have like very
different periods some people have
really like debilitating periods no
totally so I'm not gonna say if she can
do that like you can get out of bed
because maybe you can maybe you can
maybe you just need heating padding you
need to pull a Bryce yeah work from
heating pads so I just think it's
important to know like that and now
we've said it and now we've said it but
it is interesting to think about people
like doing so like right like when
Beyonce performed the you know national
anthem at the Super Bowl like she could
have been on her period and it would
have been interesting to know that so I
guess when you're at home watching the
not like other girls special cuddled up
cozy maybe you have your period yeah you
can know that you're watching a woman on
her period right it's interesting and
it's it's really exciting to see women
thriving on their period yeah because
for me it's usually the opposite so I am
like annoyed obviously like my period
could come at any time and I'm gonna get
it it's actually the best time because
at least for me personally like I'm
bloated before my period And once my
period comes de bloat that's true it's
the most d-bloated you'll be and now I
won't have my period for my trip
for the holiday travel so that's huge so
when you're watching Claudia's holiday
content just know she's not on her she's
not that's why she I will be doing the
most you know yeah yeah yeah so White
swimsuit I just really wanted to share
that I'm glad that you did I'm so glad
you're here Jackie's in town too really
support her sister and I want to tell
you it really means a lot to me like for
real tonight and tomorrow night I'm
gonna be at the Gramercy theater sorry
sold out
um and I'm filming a special and I'm
really nervous honestly I've done it
once before so like I love when I done
it I [ __ ] hate you
I've done it once before
um but it doesn't get any less scary it
really doesn't no but at least this time
you have two I know so I was just saying
that earlier like last you're really
supposed to film and I notice it when I
watch other people's comedy specials
because they'll cut to the audience and
I'm like there was a man sitting there
before and now there's a woman in the
front row so you really are supposed to
film two specials you know just in case
you [ __ ] anything up last time I did it
also last minute that I didn't get the
opportunity to film too I filmed one and
I kind of stuck it up like I was like
really nervous now I feel very calm it's
a very small venue you did like
touch-ups at the end you know I had to
like fake some stuff which like sucks
like yeah but still stream djt on Amazon
it's so good you still know the
difference and you wouldn't know the
difference but now like for me like I
feel like I'll really get the
opportunity to perform my best so that
everyone who wasn't able to come to
enlog and even those who were can enjoy
it at a TV coming soon so so excited I
feel like one of the takes will be like
the one and you'll know yes I have a
feel yeah I don't know what to predict
no I don't know what tonight but I've
got a new outfit like it's gonna be it's
kind of major it is kind of major I'm
very excited to be there and to see
enlog again I've only seen it once but I
was cracking up oh my God you've only
seen it once yeah at MSG
um well I had a show in Delaware on
Thursday that's where I got the
sweatshirt from it says wench so thank
you to the toaster who brought this and
amazing and you gave me one and it's in
the bag of laundry I did um one of my
favorite things about Jackie coming to
Newark is being tasked with the
responsibility of washing your underwear
because you usually stay close to me and
I have a washing machine but let me tell
you how doing Harry's Laundry last night
was was one of the greatest shows of my
life you do my laundry because you're
doing Harry's Laundry so yeah I gave you
my plane of course of course no I'm not
complaining now I have an extra outfit
no totally but when I tell you like it
was when I was drawing and folding like
every time I took something out of the
wash I would take it out and be like
speaking on and then fold it and then do
it all again it was
thank you for that for real like it was
really it was a glorious way to spend a
Sunday night oh you're so welcome I'm
excited about everything that you got
before she's got underwear you have too
oh really ladylike thank you so much
thank you for watching my your knickers
my bits
um just like the people who bid on the
Queen's underwear right should I put
them up for auction for The Toasters
No I um I love using the term knickers
like for underwear like but it's kind of
like a scary word like
I like I feel like I don't want to say
it anymore no don't it's one syllable
off yeah from danger zone cancellation
yeah Nation like I get like a pit before
I say it even though it's like what is
it like British for underwear yeah but
it's like you know how you just said you
know I've done it before like no I can
mispronounce things all the time no
totally I don't want to accidentally
like you know
yeah yeah yeah but it's like such a
funny way to say undies you know yeah
for a brave person for a brave person
and honestly I'm not that brave so if
you did it it's undies from here on out
you did it you climbed that mountain
today yeah oh speaking of mountains I've
climbed huge update from over the
weekend is that your girl after what is
it four or five years I have finally
started Yellowstone and I'm about to
finish season two I have so many
thoughts I'll save it was I right when I
said like you'll be like in it like
obsessed by season two yeah and then I
would say so you're like by season by
the end of season two you're like I'm
watching the rest of the show I feel
like in season one there are times when
like if you walked away from it you
wouldn't feel the need to come back well
that's what happened I had started
watching it once before in season one
I'm like this is what everyone's getting
all bent out of shape over I'm like this
kind of sucks it takes at least a season
for you to like like it also the
episodes are really slow they they're in
no rush to tell this story no they're in
no rush and I have so many thoughts by
the end of season two you're like oh
this is a show on my roster now and if
there's more episodes I want to watch
him and I think by the end of season
three you will die for this like you
will take a bullet for this show got it
okay well I'm getting there like I'm
definitely getting there yeah um and of
course your favorite actor is in season
two yes the guy who I literally talk
about on the show once a month from
Desperate Housewives who won't kiss
another woman he plays one of the Beck
Brothers and kiss another woman as an
actor like he won't do a scene where he
has to kiss a woman because that's why
he's always playing the villain because
if you can't kiss anyone like there's
limited roles for you that you're not
lovable right so in Desperate Housewives
he plays Edie's husband but he's like
this evil man now he's playing this like
evil businessman he's literally so good
at being an evil actor because it
literally is his only option yeah
yeah but he's also a good actor he's an
excellent he has he's his roster is
really good yeah
we go through the end that's it no no
there's more and then you pull up his
IMDb I can't go through this again I
think like nip talk yes and um he's in
like a Hallmark movie or something you
know because you know you don't kiss on
the Hallmark Channel of course maybe a
peck on the cheeks so in the TV recap I
will be discussing all of my thoughts
but all I want to say is I would lay my
life out on the line for rip like
because the
there there's really just no words like
I and he like I don't wanna I'm not
really not gonna give you my reactions
to what your thoughts are because
character development changes people
change like some of the people that you
might be like obsessed with like come
and go
um I'll just say like rip it just keeps
getting better I I don't doubt it for a
second and I would say I give a rip uh
I'm literally gonna say that because I
don't give a rip what anyone says like
rib is the best character I'm naming my
child rip like now I understand why um
Lauren Lane named her baby Dutton like
because my baby's gonna be named her up
like I don't know what rip is short for
you'll learn his origin story soon I did
learn his origin story with the frying
pan yeah and he's just uh like a
an anonymous person like he's not a real
person he's a cowboy yeah he's a wayward
Cowboy
so I don't even know if his mother named
him right but that's just like his name
maybe that's like his farm name right
name Ranch name okay if we keep talking
about this like I will just give all my
thoughts and I want to save it for the
TV for anyone who doesn't watch like
don't be stubborn like just do it just
do it I didn't watch this week's
Yellowstone because I flew in last night
I went to bed at seven o'clock and
Claudia is in the middle of it so I
wouldn't recap it in studio we don't
have the option of taking our headphones
off by next Monday like I should I mean
I started on Friday and I'm about to be
at season three so I Believe by next
Monday I will
excited for you because it really gets
good and you really start forming more
attachments other than red there's for
me there's no attachment other than what
do you think about John Dutton
um I like him I like him I I feel like
he kind of reminds me of Queen Elizabeth
because he's all about the Legacy but
like the one thing he could really do to
like help improve Legacy is like love
his children and like let them you know
be themselves and he won't do that
um so I do believe he's like smart and
wants what's best for the ranch but like
sometimes it just like kills me like
you know what do you know did you see
the parallel drawing I know that's a
pretty good one yeah actually they're so
similar yeah
oh and I don't know if anyone has like
made this call yet but like Yellowstone
is like succession but for Republicans
right that's the headline yeah oh that's
what everyone says so it's like
succession is like liberal City and then
liberal billionaires and then uh
Yellowstone is Republican billionaire
yeah like it's it's giving like red
State succession yeah and just wait and
am I the only one who like drew that
conclusion or like no no like that's
what it's called okay it's called
Republican yeah you know like it's
literally Republican so succession
should be called liberal Yellowstone
because Yellowstone is so much bigger
than well which came first
I couldn't tell you and succession is
based off of like a real family right
yeah it's mostly based off of the
Murdoch's Murdoch's and Yellowstone is
not based on I don't think there's a
family in Montana that owns most of them
let me tell you how Yellowstone couldn't
possibly be based on anything remotely
true because if that were the case
um there would be no one left in
Yellowstone at least 30 people died in
episode and it's supposed to be this
tiny little town I'm like where are all
these people coming from yeah Bozeman
you know Helena Helena
just wait but yes people have drawn that
conclusion but they're both really good
shows totally and it's that's really
funny like it was my first thought and I
guess yeah John is Kendall
Logan yeah what John is Logan Beth is
Siobhan
well there's not like a dude there's not
direct parallels but like she's a girl
and uh Tom is rich
yes Jamie
is Kendall yeah and the little one is
the little one Casey and Macaulay
Culkin's brother yep yeah and let me
tell you how I don't know I cannot tell
you who's the oldest like how what age
the kids go
and justice for Lay
like since I haven't watched season one
in so long like I did not remember at
all that there was another brother who
passed away in the show yeah I had no
idea it was really sad like I was like I
definitely was like teared up yeah and
now when you watch like later Seasons
like we we didn't need that brother no
totally I mean because that brother was
like the the one right yeah like he was
gonna do it so now it's just like
secession like who will succeed right
right who do you think should who do you
think will
not that we have a clear answer yet
here's like obviously what needs to
happen like Beth and rip need to get
married
and but I I don't know what look you
just gave me but I just want to say like
if rip [ __ ] dies
um I'm not gonna be okay now I feel like
he does now I feel like he does oh my
god um
can I tell you just quickly no no no he
doesn't no okay good like I'll seriously
like I wouldn't tell you that he did no
because like the way I would stop
watching but like that's clearly the
answer because you know what the only
person in this entire [ __ ] family
who's nice to Kevin Costner and respects
him and is loyal to him is rip and works
ranch right a first one out Ranch things
first one in last one out I already oh
when that [ __ ] Casey
took his house and rip had to move into
the bunk house because like now Casey's
the one who's gonna be like in training
to be the heir
I was so upset and I was so hurt for him
and the only one who was speaking back
said that point was Beth like there's a
million houses on this Ranch like give
rip deserves better rip is not a like a
wayward Cowboy yeah he's a man of
integrity yeah he's been at this Ranch
since he was 12.
I was so upset like that scene was
really upset and Casey like you know
[ __ ] for brains nothing like who doesn't
even like his family and hates the farm
and is only doing it so that he has
something to give his son it's like oh
that's only right your dad is doing
that's what everybody your dad is doing
oh my God like [ __ ] for brains I hate
him hate
like he is like he doesn't care about
anyone but his wife which is like nice
but like there's other people in the
world you know what I mean yeah and his
wife like hates everyone too
um
and like what about Tate you know like
Tate loves the ranch yeah and like they
won't live there you know yeah and like
they finally moved into the master suite
I know they're moving out like I can't I
can't that was weird like I understand
what Kevin Costner is getting there so
much you know how Kevin Costner gave up
his bedroom yeah for this chipper brains
who doesn't even want it yeah
like I get actually now in hindsight I
understand that plot line but I don't
want to give anything away no don't no I
know I said I would save my thoughts so
let's just move on because let's move on
let's move on um other things that went
down this weekend oh my god I didn't
even tell everyone what that I took my
driving test oh my God yes I was so um
Saturday was just click bathing Saturday
no
I think we should click wait really okay
because I am vlogging the whole time and
the answer is like the result is so
crazy yeah
okay and you vlogged and I vlogged it
and it should be out by the end of this
month
yeah so I had my driving test Saturday
and it was just like it was it was crazy
it was a crazy day and I didn't even
post about on my Instagram I was so
exhausted studying from studying and
driving the adrenaline like also it was
really early in the morning so anyways
it's all in the Vlog you'll catch it and
then I read the redheads book all
weekend Horse by Geraldine Brooks our
final book
horse
uh we're recording tomorrow so submit
your questions it was amazing I'm gonna
answer them from the redhead Studio
we'll be recording here oh yeah redheads
back together in person like I heard the
redheads are getting together tomorrow
to record what will be like the most
critically acclaimed episode of the
season the final one always is and then
I hear they're heading to a fabulous
event we are we are all attending
together Claudia's show that's what I
heard so if you're coming to the show
tomorrow night like lots of celebs in
Tow full force no like the redheads in
the crowd yeah so and that's like
upstage you or anything uh it's okay
but you know me I'm not like that I
wouldn't do it both nights no no you
wouldn't
um so that's really exciting and the
book was really good and I think to
Dana's choice so it's always really
literary I think snatcher was obsessed
so it's not sure I always hates it
she's so critical on books that are in
Colleen Hoover but she was obsessed here
because she loves horses right and it's
about the greatest racehorse that ever
lived and it's a true story most of it
it's historical fiction that's the one
thing about Yellowstone I don't love is
that like you know how I feel about
animals on the sets of oh God TV shows
um I just feel like I I I would love
like a you know a
behind the scenes video on you know
measures they're taking to ensure that
the horses on set are happy you know I
don't know what the measures they're
taking are but I feel so certain that
those horses are so happy also the
creator of the show uh Tyler Sheridan is
a cowboy okay he is like
a real cowboy and so he would not stand
for the Miss treatment of horses okay
and they couldn't be like preaching
everything they preach on the show and
then be like abusing animals animals and
like Farm life right so if anybody's
like read any interesting articles like
that you know
I just want to know more about the
animals I don't think you're gonna find
anything but yeah sure go sniffing
around yeah that's what I'm gonna do so
send me your articles I'm sure you're
going to find amazing things out there
that's what I'm looking for and how
these horses are stars and they have
confidence like they've never had them
no they have like so many followers on
Instagram and all the other girl horses
want them yeah exactly and they get like
food to hay for days days and days
so
um
so I still have more Yellowstone recap
so let's so let's get into the stories
yes because we didn't do a show on
Friday because I was in Delaware so
we've got lots to discuss we do so
without further Ado here are the past
five stories that you need to know and
today's Fast Five is brought to you bye
your bedroom deserves a refresh and now
is the perfect time to elevate the most
important room in your home with Zuma
introducing the bed by thuma handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood you'll find beautiful unique
variations in the natural grain the
minimalist design featuring Japanese
joinery helps Elevate any space it's
super supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and it's made to naturally
minimize noise and create space the
perfect platform bed just got even
better you can now customize the bed by
choosing between the original pillow
board for the new solid wood headboard
the fabric pillar board adds a softness
and color to anything space while
headboards offer the sleek and solid
support the headboard attaches directly
to the bed and it uses Japanese joinery
so no tools are required you can buy it
with the bed or its own upgrade or its
own as an upgrade thuma practices
intentional less is more design
Philosophy for the bedroom with clean
lines subtle curves and lifestyle
enhancing details fuma proves that
Simplicity is the truest form of
sophistication
so if you're looking for a new bed head
to thuma first of all it comes in three
easy maneuver boxes no tools are
required it can take around five minutes
and it's really going to save you and
your partner from future legal filings
of divorce create that feeling of
checking into your favorite boutique
hotel suite but at home with the bed by
thuma go to thuma.co toast to receive a
25 credit towards your purchase of the
bed plus free shipping in the
continental US go to
thumatuma.co Dot
toast thuma dot Co slash toast for 25
credit today's episode is also brought
to you by honey love I'm so excited
about this new sponsor because this is
what we were talking about last week
when we were both wearing the same bra
um the shapewear that I wear every
single show since I've ever done comedy
is from honey love I bought it years ago
off of a Facebook ad it was targeted
towards the girly and now I all my
shapewear is from honey love I'm so glad
that they are sponsoring today's episode
because holiday parties are just around
the corner and if you ready if you are
ready to look your best support for
today's episode comes from honey love we
all know that with dressing up there's
always the lack of comfort that comes
with shapewear most shapewear makes you
feel like you're suffocating but not
with honey love they are on a mission to
create the most comfortable and
effective shapewear for all of us ladies
out there and that's why I wear them on
stage because they are so comfortable I
can't be wearing like these corset tight
ass I need something that's going to
hold me in but that's also going to like
clean up let me breathe and every I
swear without without fail every single
time I've ever done a show I'm wearing
Honey Love that's also something good to
know when you're watching her special
one day she's on her period and she's
wearing honey love amen to that sister
you deserve to say big this holiday
season so for a limited time you can get
honey love on sale get 20 off your
entire order with code toast at
honeylove.com so that's
h-o-n-e-y-l-o-v-e.com code toast so as
we're reflecting on the gear there's a
couple things we're thankful for and
honey love is one of them
shop at honeylove.com code toast the
superpower short is helping ladies ever
wear sculpt and smooth their stomach to
thigh by offering just the perfect
amount of restriction so that superpower
short is their number one best seller it
has targeted compression technology that
distinguishes between areas where you
want more support and areas where you
need less their signature X targets and
sculpts your midsection without
squeezing your natural curves it's
designed to work with your body so treat
yourself again for 20 off at
honeylove.com with code toast that's
code toast at honeylove.com feel and
look as sexy as possible these holidays
with honey love shapewear because you
deserve it amazing thank you so much
mcclardia you're welcome
okay our first story some exciting news
from this weekend Kiki Palmer is
pregnant she's expecting her first child
with boyfriend Darius Jackson Kiki
Palmer is going to be a mom the 29 year
old actress and now she's expecting her
first child on SNL this weekend
she said during her monologue there are
some rumors going around people have
been in my comments saying Kiki's having
a baby Kiki's pregnant and I want to set
the record straight I am she said as she
opened her blazer to reveal her baby
bump as the crowd cheered she said you
know I gotta say though it is bad when
people on the internet spread rumors
about you but it's even worse when
they're correct but honestly this has
been the biggest blessing and I'm so
excited guys I'm gonna be a mom let me
tell you how I didn't hear the rumor
once that's the only like thing I'm a
little curious about
um like I didn't hear them I'm sure in
her comments like people were saying it
also she was at the cfda awards recently
she was wearing like a big dress that
would conceal a bomb so I'm sure like no
I don't want to like attack you but the
real Kiki fans wow wow
[Music]
um
let me tell you I'm so happy for Kiki
Palmer like I really love her I feel
like she's really in this like Great era
of her life and her career and like a
baby on top of that I just feel like
it's so amazing I thought this was such
a cool way to announce like of course
um it's like a once in a lifetime
opportunity it's kind of like when um it
reminded me Beyonce Love On Top vma's
belly
I love this for her I'm so happy and I
just like I wake up every day and I'm
like I hope Keke Palmer you know kills
it today and she has been yeah and this
is a wonderful joyous occasion on top of
all the perspressional express success
yeah that she's been experiencing did
you watch her SNL episode I did not but
I did see you know clips of certain
sketches that were pretty she's very
funny and SNL is like but did they know
like how to use her I think they really
Let Her Shine like they did a Keenan and
Kel sketch that's what I heard and it
wasn't a Live sketch it was like a
pre-recorded commercial thing but it was
so funny first of all for like any Kenan
and Kel fans it was huge because they're
both Nickelodeon kids right and so Kiki
was like really just like
exposing herself as like a huge Keenan
and kelp fan it was so funny it was
really good that was all I saw so I
don't know enough about to like say how
the episode was as a whole but I feel
confident that it was good Kiki's like
she's super funny anything less than
great no she's really like a star and
I'm so glad she's finally being you know
seen for that first of all I didn't even
know she had a boyfriend I know me
neither I love that she keeps that part
of her life private because in the words
of Taylor Swift from the song Paris
privacy sign on the door and on my page
and on the whole world romance is not
dead if you keep it just yours oh that's
sweet yeah just because we don't know
about it doesn't mean it's not real you
know no not even close that's like not
even close yeah she thinks apples and
oranges I love that for KiKi knowing and
realness are not related ain't nothing
because I feel like this is going to be
the year of knowing things what do you
want to know
wow that's a really tough question well
first I want to know how the horses are
being treated on Yellowstone
I'm so excited for the flood of DMS
you're going to receive being like I
work on Yellowstone or my friend us and
the horses are they're from a sanctuary
it's better than the stripes brother
that's what I want to know I love I
don't want to be right I don't want to
be right Jackie I know I don't want to
be right you're not I don't want to be
like you just assume that I do like
Hollywood Jackie if you're a horse a
working horse
I don't think there's a better job in
the world than being a horse on
Yellowstone the pampering the scenery
it's just and they just like let the
horses do their thing and there's one
season you'll see it might be season
four
where they just like decided to be extra
cowboy and they like put in all of these
gratuitous just horses like Rodeo scenes
like it's it's Cowboy porn got it you'll
notice when it happens oh my God
okay I'm not gonna say because it just
reminds me try not to make each story
about Yellowstone okay but remind me
when we do actually finally start
talking about Yellowstone remind me
about Jimmy
okay actually okay I will it's so hard
for me not to speak and I'm like I'm so
happy that you're watching lgm I'm just
like so frustrated of all the hours I've
spent like recapping it by myself and
like getting I feel like you really
haven't done them and having all of this
excitement like I feel like you're being
hella dramatic like I feel like we
didn't even talk about Yellowstone that
much because you don't [ __ ] let me no
but like no because
let's talk about
Jing yeah
I get like two minutes while you are
like and then it's moving on you know
what this victim mentality from you
listen I don't it's getting older I'm
Jackie I'm just letting you know the
truth of it no I feel like I definitely
silence you on certain things that you
really honestly need to be silent Sun
Yellowstone I have not I feel like you
never even bring it up like that's why I
haven't watched it because you never
talk about it someone roll the tapes
please of me trying to and getting like
two minutes glad you enjoyed that that's
what you do to me okay when I talk about
RuPaul everything you watch I ask
questions I make predictions
how's that one doing hardly man you
don't even realize hardly Cutie's gate
what'd she say what'd he say oh by the
way sorry for excuse me for trying to
keep the show relevant yeah everyone
scares cuties they do they cared about
cutie skate Love is Blind I'm not wrong
about that seconds Yellowstone is
forever Yellowstone is forever
how'd you get here
the horses what do you want to know so
you're knowing things yeah what do you
want to know well I'm so happy for Kiki
Palmer for real love this journey for
her wishing her all the best I love
I love a celebrity pregnancy
announcement I really do
yeah and this is as good as it gets on
SNL it's like so major and you made a
great call yeah the Audio I feel like
people are gonna use that on their Tick
Tock and their reels to announce their
pregnancies yeah it'll be that and then
like a couple months later so I'm 34
weeks today yep I love that yeah and the
mean that's like next thing I knew I was
pregnant I don't know that one it's from
Kylie's um
video Kylie's first video and she's like
sitting there with her belly out and
she's like next thing I know I was
pregnant so it's like once you know rip
picks up a pill okay I know I'm pregnant
no and like last night before bed like
not me being delusional I'm like Ben
kind of looks like rip
no and like they definitely they both
have beautiful smiles and they're both
like chubby brunettes like I think
there's something there can you call a
boy a brunette I feel like what kind of
question I feel like brunette is a is a
female word
that's what you'd say a boy with brown
hair
think about it okay but if a boy was
blonde would you say boy with yellow
hair with a lack of hair
I'm thinking about it and I don't agree
okay hold on let me Google it brunette
is not exclusively not you being binary
oh yikes brunette definition okay it is
a person it's a person okay a person
with a person typically a woman with
dark brown hair what I swear and then
the next one of brunette as an adjective
having dark brown hair typically used of
a woman
my mind is blown I'm I'm surprised that
that's in the dictionary not just like
colloquially like yeah just not just
like a feeling I have yeah right right
you know I'm like because I'm like your
feelings dumb but it's not
and it's like the dictionary feels as
weird about it as I do like sometimes
typically typically wait so what do you
say with a boy with brown hair boy with
Runner yeah black of hair well male or
female they're black of hair right
yeah okay what about blonde search
blonde is blonde typically female no
blonde is a color brunette is not a
color I don't think oh you know what I
mean oh a brunette is a person person oh
brunette is a noun blonde is an
adjective
you're right but nobody he was brunette
it could also be an adjective that's why
in the Oxford thing it said blonde I
don't think is ever uh oh no he's a
blonde that would it could be a noun is
also a code the Amanda armas movie oh no
blonde definition
blonde can be an adjective or a noun
safer and same for redhead
yeah but not for lack of hair but also
redhead can also be a podcast
and redheads could also be a book club
such a good call yeah
um so yeah Ben kind of looks like red
yeah but you should get him like blue
jeans clothes that rip might wear if he
went to New York City you know don't
have him dressed like a cowboy rip in
New York City I'm not okay no the city
would combust he would eat his City up
rip would love New York no he'd be like
getting a hot dog oh yeah maybe they're
talking trash no last night I watched an
episode where Beth and Ripper on the
roof
Okay and like that's when like they
realize like they're in love and she's
like don't say it
um but I was cackling because she was
like you probably have a lot of money
like you obviously you don't spend any
money on the clothes you would bring
since I met you I was cackling and then
he was like no I actually spent thirty
thousand dollars on the gravestone and
twenty thousand questions to make it
deep no like
like like I felt and by the way when
when she said the thing about jeans he
cackled and we saw his smile and we
never see him smile and I was like rip
you should really smile more she cracks
him up he'll only smile if it's worth it
yeah and she's like literally psychotic
um how are you feeling about her
obsessed like that scene where like you
know he saved her and oh my God like I
can't like he broke down the whole
office wall because those guys were
holding her and her assistant hostage
and her assistant died he was a good
assistant
um
that scene obviously is like like a
moment
um and like things are different now
between them and like I I really didn't
like Beth okay I'll talk about in the
next okay I'm sorry the next story are
you ready for it it's really another
amazing couple news Prince William and
Kate Middleton ended their three-day
trip to the us at the Earth shot prize
ceremony so William and Kate were here
in Boston
for this event as we stayed on Thursday
they went to the Celtics game and then
they dialed up the glamor for their
glitzy Earth shot prize ceremony on
Friday night so she wore a floor-length
bright green gown by Solace London which
she rented from a UK rental you know
fashion pass Rent the Runway site she
rented it for UK fashion pass she rented
it for a hundred dollars from the
website which is called her and h-u-r-r
for our UK toasters and paired it with
an emerald choker from her mother-in-law
Princess Diana and earrings from her own
private collection the choker was also
seen on Queen Mary about a hundred years
ago so it's just extremely iconic okay
I'm gonna see something like crazy and
like kind of stupid but like I genuinely
sometimes forget that Diana was
William's mom too
because like the way that people talk
about it it's like it's always like
Harry like oh because like he kind of
like was her favorite you know like the
youngest and like she gave him special
attention because William got all the
attention because he was the heir
um so I'm like why is Kate wearing this
random woman's necklace like I forget
about the connection because they're
always like Harry didn't want to see
that happen to his his wife to his
mother it's always like Harry and Diana
yeah but it's like William it's also
audiencing that right so I just this was
a nice reminder for me that um Diana had
two children not just one
um the other thing is I love that
William and Kate are walking the walk
here I feel like all these celebrities
are always preaching about climate
change and like literally doing nothing
about it so even though I'm sure in
their personal life they take plenty of
jets and gowns but to go to an event
about climate change and fly commercial
and where I rented dress like that is
walking the walk oh and by the way to
wear a vintage necklace right she didn't
buy new jewelry everything recycled
um and it was recycled before Diana too
like this necklace is hundreds of years
old there's like not a new thing on her
so I'm not dumb enough to think that
they bring that energy to everything
that they do but publicly like it is
always silly when someone is out here
talking about climate change before they
get on their jet so I appreciated that
and she looked gorgeous I was like one
of her best looks yet but also because
the photos like I don't know the
lighting the the flashes no I think you
had a little work done her like she
looked like she had some filler under
her eyes her face looked great but like
the color of the photos was and also
it's the color of the dress and the
carpet was green too and they were like
mismatched greens but they didn't Clash
so that was the only thing I didn't like
about the whole that the cartoon was
that the carpet was green and that like
it didn't work like if the carpet was
like a Cerulean blue or like you know it
was Earth shot it should be the color of
the earth like blue yeah okay maybe if
the carbo was blue it would have been
even better but I actually I love the
carpet I love the dress with the carpet
it just all together is like it's a
moment photo moment for these two and
they take a lot of pictures I can't
recall like any other than their wedding
like really iconic photos that they have
photos and this is probably my favorite
moment of them yet I agree they don't
have like a they're so protocol like
they're always they don't ever look like
they like each other because they're so
pretty they're like standing there with
their hands like tights yeah they were
being cute and it felt warm yeah I wish
that they could take like some nice
photos but like they're always having to
like be so proper yeah but that's why we
don't really have any moments from them
because like they both do the letter of
the law to a t yeah no but it was truly
a fabulous evening for them David
Beckham was there you know he stands
respects so I hope they had a great time
in America I hope they come back soon
people in America especially Boston
people like they were obsessed to see
like the droves of people waiting
outside their hotel like and probably so
crazy like go to a different country and
I'm sure they have like their own POV on
America like I'm sure they'd like think
that America hates them because like
America really took Harry and Megan's
side yes so I'm sure it feels like an
unfriendly territory but then you know
they went to there there was like
millions of people standing outside
waiting for pictures it was raining
people were waiting in the rain I saw a
bunch of toasters there they were
putting footage in our Facebook group
like I saw you know the back of her so
I'm sure they thought it might be
hostile
because I don't think they like love
America yeah because I don't think they
think America loves them yeah but I
think you can find people who love
people who don't but by the way to show
up and show out an actual trailer
dropped I saw this morning it's good
they it's gonna be a two-part this
Friday next Friday oh wow we're ready
this Friday yeah December 8th and it's
pretty much exactly what we thought it
was going to be like it's I feel as
though like I've been still holding out
hope like that there's something it's
not it's
it looks like it's going to be
gloves are off yeah well at least there
wasn't anything oh no there was the
picture of the family and they said
there's a hierarchy in within the family
it's like yeah because some people are
Kings and some people are princess and
some people are no bodies
um and you guys are pretty high up
actually right but
the I thought what was most contentious
was like you know it was obviously the
mirroring Diana and Megan with the
paparazzi
um and then them saying like nobody was
protecting us and they were planting
stories and photos
so well I I'm
one just excited to watch too I hope the
documentary format can like shed more
light on like these stories that they're
talking about because so much news comes
out like from the palace about the
palace and I have no idea like what's
real and also because we're over here
like I think the media over there is
very different that's what I've heard
when she like when they're talking about
like these nasty stories in the Press
like I have no idea what they're talking
about because here was always glowing
right so I look forward to seeing like
headlines cover pages photos that were
taken yeah and no that's actually a
really good point it's like a perfect
way for them to Showcase all of that and
and I could like see it you know there's
it's literally time stamped like yeah
we'll recognize what the names of the
Publications are if it's the big ones
versus that's actually so true requires
of the UK right because when they talk
about
the the negative press
it it's my for my POV like American
Press loved them and continues to love
them so I guess you're right like it's I
really forget that like it's a different
country yeah no because I would always
like say that like I feel like the Press
loves them like the media loves and they
get so much amazing media attention but
then like UK toasters will come in and
be like no it was really bad here for
Megan like the the headlines think they
were so racist racist horrible towards
her and I don't get you know the UK
press to my doorstep do I have no I
don't even like see
I guess there's no really way to see
what like the cover of the UK newspaper
is right here no I've seen there's like
the famous one is Straight Out of
Compton from The Daily Mail oh no I
haven't seen that in the headline but
the new princess is Straight Out of
Compton yeah that's the one that like
I've seen everywhere oh I didn't even
see that the one that I think of is like
how when Megan and Kate wore like very
similar looks like the way that they
describe Kate's outfits versus the way
they describe Megan something like that
yeah so I I hope that they explain it
all too
more than Daily Mail because it's like
you didn't leave the royal family
because of the Daily Mail Right no
actually that was the attitude from
everyone right but uh but we're both
talking about like Daily Mail cases it
has to be like a full because I don't
follow like the sun you know of course
so what I'm saying is I'm interested
really interested to see exactly what
they were experiencing and what they're
talking about yeah and where does the
footage start
you know what I mean like oh I feel like
they're personal footage their personal
footage probably starts like six months
or a year ago when they decided to do
this and then they will use like old
press footage yes all the stuff that was
like them doing events and yeah exactly
but they probably sat down for it six
months ago and over time they
interviewed other people you you hear me
yeah Melanie Bromley Vibes yeah yeah who
was she I don't know she was speaking
with authorial expert yeah yeah she
better be like actually an expert not
someone like I don't want to hear from
like a podcaster about what they think
happened like I want insiders who are on
the ground yeah because this is serious
business it's documentary yeah like it's
an I don't need to it's not like um
everyone's opinions right
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that's brought to you by
true classic yes it is the holidays are
here and there is plenty of t-shirts
here thanks to our sponsor true classic
if you don't know what to get a gift for
the men in your life try giving them the
best fitting basic tea out there our
friends at true classic are on a mission
to maximize men's confidence by
elevating their style they've already
helped over 2 million men look great in
their t-shirts and now you can save
while you do so you can get 25 off true
classic with our exclusive link
trueclassic.com toast and the discount
doesn't just stop there you'll save even
more during their new their latest
sitewide sale support our show and check
them out at trueclassic.com toast almost
all men's t-shirts are designed to look
good on a certain body type luckily true
Classics team designed t-shirts to make
the fellas of all sizes out there look
confident and feel good in their
clothing ABS flabs dad bod or pass the
dad bod with true classic shirts you'll
get the best fit I'm always trying to
get Ben to buy new shirts because like
he literally has the same shirts from
high school that he chewed holes in in
the collar and I'm just like look nice
in the T-shirt like just because wearing
a t-shirt doesn't mean it doesn't have
to look bad know and you can be styling
like rip like rip rip would love true
classes because he is a true classic it
was made for him Zach got a delivery of
the true classic shirts and I have a new
husband literally and I have new shirts
to steal and they're wonderful wonderful
so true classic tees taper off towards
the bottom but they fit tighter around
the chest and the shoulders so it's the
desired look what that everybody type
wants to achieve they also offer other
menswear ranging from polos to workout
shirts to even boxers and briefs so get
25 off at trueclassic.com toast free
shipping is included on purchases over a
hundred dollars that's 25 off at
trueclassic.com toast Santa won't be the
only one slaying thanks to True classic
today's episode is also brought to you
by bowling Branch the holidays are the
most exciting time of the year and if
you want to enjoy them to the fullest
you'll need to get your best sleep every
night and it's easier than it sounds
thanks to bowling Branch if you're
looking for the softest most luxurious
organic cotton sheets from Bowling
branch check it out why it's turning me
like that
are made from the finest 100 organic
cotton threads on Earth and they make a
difference that you can truly feel night
after night so their products are made
differently at bowling Branch made from
the finest 100 organic cotton on Earth
that means they're free from toxins
pesticides and harsh chemicals at every
step of its making it's also made by
Artisans who earn the pay and respect
that they deserve so you can fall asleep
at peace knowing that these sheets are
not only comfortable but they're made
the right way the bowl and Branch Way
Jack and I both have Bowlen Branch the
signature hemmed collection which comes
from Twin to California King we both
have king-sized beds the signature hemp
collection is truly everything of the
sort we also both have throw blankets I
have the waffle throw so do you right
you have it at my house and in my
bedroom yeah it's really the best uh bed
sheets out there it also makes a great
gift bring home a better night's sleep
this holiday season with bowl and Branch
bedding for a limited time get 20 off
your first set of sheets and free
shipping when you use promo code toast
at bowlingbranch.com that's b-o-l-l a
and
branch.com promo code
toastbowlingbranch.com promo code t o a
s t thank you bowling Branch for
sponsoring today's episode thank you
you're welcome
what are you staring at me like that for
I'm not you text me like a secret no no
I didn't okay what I don't know I guess
I'm just like looking at you what else
am I supposed to do with myself your job
like what's the next story
Balenciaga drops to 25 million suit
against producers of the controversial
disgusting campaign valenciaga said on
Friday that it's dropping it's a million
25 million lawsuit against the producers
of their recent
um ad campaign the fashion house filed
the suit a week earlier against a
production company and set designer
after it's spring 2023 campaign included
documents from a Supreme Court case
about child pornography the brand also
faced backlash for the separate campaign
that showed children holding teddy bears
in bondage outfits they put out a
lengthy statement about the following
actions uh that they would take with the
ejected to learn from their mistakes as
an organization they have one new
control instances their current process
for Content validation has failed and
they recognize the need to do better
they also have a new organization
reorganizing their image Department to
ensure full alignment with their
corporate guidelines the lawsuit they
decided not to pursue litigation that's
the headline here yeah they also want to
learn and contribute we want to learn
help and contribute to Tech children
sure so we are starting trainings on
responsible communication across our
teams I just like don't think you need
to have right a whole initiative at your
company it's like not sexually exploit
children training after campaign if you
need training for your employees on how
to not sexually exploit children you are
the problem so obviously your lawsuit
was dropped because it's you yeah no and
the lawsuit being dropped obviously
proves that like the people who take the
pictures they didn't choose these things
yeah and if they actually did pursue
little litigation at least just to like
look like they're pretending like it
wasn't them like things would have come
that would have proven that it was them
like you know people who work like email
okay I got the teddy bears you get the
Supreme Court what should we print what
coffee table books should we have now
yeah no stock messages like yeah like
these things are communicated about so I
think it would have been pretty damning
for them
um they said together with my team we
will go on a listening tour to engage
with advocacy advocacy groups who aim to
protect children from you
like don't let them near anyone they
said donation we have set aside a
significant fund for Grants to
organizations so that we can help make a
difference in protecting children I just
want to say like they're they just keep
say protecting children like it's a
blanket statement for everything and
it's it's weird it's like it feels like
someone has a gun ahead they're like I
want to protect children protect
children I love to protect the children
like do you even know what that means
you might think protecting them is
giving them a teddy bear no and like we
are protecting children from you like
that's the real like it's nice that they
want to do all these things yeah I think
a better use of your time would be to
look inward no at Balenciaga We Stand
Together for children's safety and do
not clearly not like I don't need a
fashion brand to like have to let them
know that they stand for children's
safety like yeah it should be implied as
just being a human being on Earth
children safety and if anything that you
do especially like multiple times over
gives the idea and the impression that
you don't then that's enough for me then
you have failed at protecting children
yeah no this Saga is so [ __ ] weird to
me and it like never ends and it keeps
getting weirder and this lawsuit was
[ __ ] and you're right if they had
proceeded with it like it would have
been really bad for them yeah like
between depositions and everything they
would have had to come out
um
and at the end of the day it wouldn't
have even been successful because again
like Balenciaga is in charge of what
Balenciaga puts out who they contract to
do the work for them is irrelevant it
starts at the top right and again like
this is
campaign after campaign like little
details it's not just one hour it's not
just one it's not just like two it seems
very intentional and they thought
subliminal but also the thing about the
teddy bears and the harnesses I don't
know if I said this like the first time
that we saw it it's like oh they're like
we shouldn't have put children in that
campaign but like who else are you
making teddy bears for if not children
with harnesses right no but like what
who'd make a teddy bear for like your
adult customers right so you're making
teddy bears for kids with harnesses
whether their kids are not in the
campaign like doesn't matter it's still
you intended to disseminate harnessed
but teddy bears to the children harness
teddy bears 100 that's so true so I
don't like yes we need an apology for
the kids in the campaign like and
everything else but like also the [ __ ]
are you doing making harness teddy bears
let's walk through the thought process
for sure yeah who's the target demo here
who is the target demo not me
no and not the children they don't want
your nasty teddy bears no they don't
Justice for teddy bears Justice for Ted
put on that harness you know who we
really need as like an advocate here Ted
he would put these these exactly like
that teddy bear he'd be like
because he's an adult no that's because
he's [ __ ] 40. by the way no
Stacks yeah Ted is 40. yeah Ted you know
can engage in whatever sexual conduct he
likes as a grown-ass man when you think
about the movie Ted through the context
of Ted being 40 it's like a lot more sad
yeah no like Ted's unemployed like Ted
Ted's an alcoholic cuts and alcohol in
Texas addiction to drugs like it's sad
we need Ted three like honestly
I don't I think Ted one is so perfect I
don't Ted two I don't find her I don't
know her it doesn't work for me because
Mila Kunis was the only one oh yeah it
was meant for that role I think his name
was John yeah and his as His companion
there was no reason why they should have
broken up they haven't seen Ted in so
long I have to watch it so [ __ ] good
it's a perfect film yeah so I think Ted
should come out
and like end-to-down splenciaga because
coming from Ted it's like this is too
far even for me can I tell you something
a fun fact about me like a cool fact
about me yeah that you've met I've met
Ted like the doll well yes I met Seth
macfarland as well but the doll yeah
I've been in the presence of the doll
it's really cool I think I even have a
picture of it somewhere no that's really
cool yeah you do a lot of cool stuff and
not all of it impresses me but that
that's cool that is [ __ ] cool yeah
I'm proud I'm proud of that one yeah and
Seth macfarland too he's impressive yeah
where's he been um I don't know I went
to his birthday party it was really fun
it was Halloween I wrote about it in my
book yeah and like it was not a costume
party but like there was a couple people
there in costumes and like really dumb
ones I need a job and like she looks
stupid and I actually felt bad for her
like it was the only time in my life I
think I'd ever feel pity for Nina Dobrev
you know
but I did I felt pity anyways it's just
not going away for Balenciaga and I have
to commend The Mamas and the influencers
for keeping him alive because the
celebrities are doing [ __ ] nothing
nothing
and I don't know where we go from here
with like certain people no I know and
Lisa Arena stepped in a hole oh yeah
again she gave the um most bizarre
statement on Instagram no it wasn't
bizarre it was like condescending and
backhandling let me read it she's so
dumb people want her to talk about
Balenciaga and she wants to talk about
anti-Semitism let's talk about Kanye hey
[ __ ] let's talk about both how many
stories can you have on your Instagram
no it's so true like why can't both
things be true no why can't you get like
a hundred slides on Instagram a day I
think talk about you do get 100. talk
about both
ugh I can't find it she deleted it but
I'm you know those accounts like go to
like oh no I went to Twitter or just
search on Instagram Lisa Rena because it
was really dominant and it actually
deserves to be dragged so let me do that
quickly so here we go like I'll take the
time today you know
or you know you didn't have to post that
anything found it because it's not like
she's an actual paid spokesperson for
Blends she wore an outfit you know you
don't have to but like she is
um
like her daughters are like models like
she's like a relevant person like she
speaks about things all the time she's
just a person but people weren't sitting
around waiting to hear what Lisa thought
about it so if she didn't want to
actually talk about it she saying
nothing would have been better than what
she said otherwise I wouldn't have
thought about her in this context here's
what she said people want me to speak
out on Balenciaga yes those ads were
wrong I think we all agree on that I
want to speak out on anti-Semitism and
hate and racism and homophobia and Alex
Jones and Kanye West Trump and Elon Musk
and the danger of that to me that's
what's really [ __ ] dangerous silence
is complicity and then this person
posted it um side by side with the
picture of Lisa and Harry Hamlin dressed
as
Nazis
yeah so I I do believe that two things
can be true we should definitely talk
about anti-Semitism off a list of
everything she wants to talk about but
why not like chat why isn't child
exploitation in there too no but she
wants to protect everyone but what about
children no but Jackie like at least
we're not she's like I want to talk
about all these things you do I feel
like you're always talking about Trump
you're always talking about Elon she's
always talking about these things like
that's her platform so I just don't see
how the first paragraph has anything to
do with the second paragraph why can't
kids be on that list of Jews of the LGBT
community like why can't she add kids to
her list no that's too far it makes no
sense like
talk about like bringing like what it's
literally that sound why the [ __ ] do you
have to bring that up like it's I
believe in talking about anti-Semitism
probably more than anyone on the planet
and like I still don't understand why
she brought it up yeah
because it's like you want to talk about
so do it do you want to talk about
exercise semitism go I don't see you no
and also it's like then when you're
someone who like talks about everything
all the time like then you also need to
speak up about this right right right
right
right right right right
and it's just like you're letting us
know that you don't want to which is
just a weird Flex
this is so crystal clear that it's
[ __ ] up by the way that's what it is
like you're just letting us know that
you don't want to talk about it and like
you're being
pressured to but you don't want to and
that makes me look at you sideways right
because also you're not being made by
Balenciaga so like right can't you just
say this camera right quite literally
nothing to lose yeah but she thinks
she's like a Hollywood Elite girly and
so she's siding with them which is like
we're just gonna wait for it to blow
over but that's why it's so important
that we don't let it right like she's
actually like the perfect example of
somebody who quite literally has no
scruples
yeah
okay ready for our next story yeah
Rihanna's Savage Xfinity settles a
consumer protection lawsuit for 1.2
million dollars Rihanna's Savage
ex-friendly will pay 1.2 million dollars
to set her settle a consumer protection
lawsuit this lawsuit claims that the
brand used deceptive marketing tactics
to automatically enroll customers in a
VIP subscription I'm surprised [ __ ] like
this doesn't happen more yeah the way
like you sign up for a seven day free
trial and then without your consent
you're paying 50 a month like I feel
like normalized having these lawsuits
because we are constantly like no I
literally had to download an app the
other day for a teleprompter dude by the
way I told you delete it did you cancel
no it was a seven day free trial it
hasn't been seven days
the way they really trick you you have
to read the wording oh my god did you
pay per year 100
did happen right because I thought it
was a good app that I'll never need to
use again do you know how to cancel
subscriptions Oh wait we're yeah no wait
oh cancel free trial cancel for trial oh
my God because it was about to renew oh
my God see tomorrow the way like that
they definitely take advantage of
people's gone yeah they take advantage
of people so I hope that I I'm sorry for
Rihanna that sucks to lose a million
dollars but I think that lawsuits like
this need to be more common like the way
we're constantly being Bamboozled yeah
the lawsuit states that Savage X Fenty
failed to quote get the proper consent
or give proper notices for the automatic
renewal charges falsely advertising the
ability to use store credit and
misleading the public over the prices of
its products which includes includes
bras underwear sleepwear and loungewear
I had something with this recently like
where they renewed something without
telling me and I was like excuse me I
did not consent to this and they were
like okay we won't do it again I'm like
but what about the last one what about
that no justice for the consumers like
we're constantly being blackballed and
Bamboozled and Hoodwinked yeah it's
constant it's constant it's like like
aren't we paying for enough no it we're
not
we're literally not like the product by
the way what we are the product what do
you mean like you know when um
in documentaries when they're like if
something is free and you're a user on
it like then you become the product yeah
our data us our information
because they know what bras you want
what undies so true what tampons you use
when you have your period and now that
you've complimented my undies I'm sure
you'll be served up for a pair for
yourself yeah no but they know what I
wear and they know what you want and
they know we're sisters for sure yeah
and they listen to the toes we make it
really easy totally we put all of our
information on the talk like right next
to our phones about every single thought
we have look let me tell you I really
want a new lawnmower and I think that my
lawn
at my vacation house because you guys
are you know I live in the city my my
lawnmower for my vacation house is they
don't know you bought a vacation house
so I bought a vacation house but you
weren't looking on Zillow so they're not
going to believe you okay so it has to
be no I'm actually always on sale maybe
you're visiting a friend and you want to
bring the lawnmower okay so you know I'm
going to see my friend Brian Jackie um
and you know he has this amazing farm
and I want to get him a gift and I'm
thinking a lawn mower
would be a really good gift I've heard
John Deere is good but I also heard they
have great options at Home Depot and I'm
sure that like there's really great DTC
Brands new yeah
shipped directly so I'm going to keep
browsing yeah let me know if you find
any I'm Gonna Keep browsing for a
lawnmower in New York
yeah that's what I'm gonna do great yeah
let me know so I want to say I don't
support you know women losing Millions
but this billion this particular lawsuit
I'm here for and I hope to see more of
it I think that it's you know obviously
not a huge financial burden for Rihanna
and it sets a good precedent agreed so
it's a win-win it's a precedent that has
been set 100 that was a good one a very
good one as opposed to a bad one as
opposed to a not very good one are you
ready for our fifth and final story yes
so I can finally talk about Yellowstone
more drama between TJ Holmes and Amy
roback as they are taken off air
indefinitely with new anchors stepping
in to host gma3 today as ABC execs take
a hard line so a lot more is coming out
about these two and it's not the fairy
tale we thought it was on Thursday okay
I do still ship though there's more
context that we need to add first of all
like TJ's ex-wife is the one who hired a
pi and got these photos taken so we were
correct in our assessment that like
these two were tailed and you know she
probably feels really good about that
decision and I feel really happy for her
because look at the way this random
story blew up about two nobodies I know
and I don't know if she expected this
many people to care but we do then they
were on the air on Friday joking out
about how it's been like such a great
week and they can't wait for the
weekends literally
um and I thought that like GMA
especially because I was putting it out
there like we're here for this like run
with it like we should we thought they
could lean in I thought GMA might lead
in but they're so [ __ ] like corporate
such [ __ ] no they're waiting to see
how things shake out like it where
people land on this so they took them
off the air I think they want to see how
people feel about that they're gonna put
in some temps see how people feel about
that and just wait and see instead of
being like you know what like these two
we ship they're consenting adults
nothing crazy happened other than like
infertility other than infidelity which
you know we're not is not illegal so
like make a choice or fire them you know
I do think it's interesting how like a
decision in your personal life can
affect your job
because while it is frowned upon it's
not illegal in any way the only thing
that they they could say is uh it
violates their contract or something
yeah like and especially if maybe one of
them is a little bit more senior they
could say they're off the air until an
investigation is conducted to make sure
that they went by protocol also like
when you are working for a big company
you start dating someone you should let
HR know so yeah they could say that you
know they're it's not like they had an
extramarital affair with Orlando yeah
and so maybe that's what they're leaning
into but I just wish they would take a
stance and like and have some Scruples
yeah no and like how do you I imagine
the ratings like do you think I
literally have ever watched the third
hour of GMA in my life I don't even know
they went past two hours so I used four
hours who knew like you'll never be the
Today Show but go off I I was so
invested and so from a PR perspective
like just lean in yeah I think I if I
were them I would lean in but if you're
so morally outraged then do something
about it yeah but now a lot of stuff has
come out about the two of them which is
really interesting like this is not TJ's
first Affair he or her first Affair TJ
allegedly was having an affair with one
of The Producers on the show for many
years and I read this on dumois so if
it's not true blame her
um that she
thank you Amy I see I don't even know
these people Amy had a years-long affair
with Matt Lauer the formerly disgraced
host well the currently disgraced former
host
um so confusing so this is a layered a
layered event you wanted to get more
layered because I thought she looked
familiar and then she came to me she was
the one who was caught on the hot mic
talking about Jeffrey Epstein when she
said when they're recording this like
Virginia gafar story and she goes off
the air but she's still wearing her mic
and she was like this makes me so mad we
had this story years ago and I wasn't
allowed yeah to run with you right and
someone clipped that and leaked it
someone who works for ABC at the time
she like had to issue you know a hostage
statement yeah talking out of her ass
yeah and that no one's done doing
anything yeah I'm surprised she still
works there after that maybe by the way
this is the maybe they've been wanting
to get rid of her ever since but they
couldn't fire her for that because she
literally was just no I'm I think that
at if they didn't fire her for that I
think they're waiting to see how people
feel so I just want it out there like I
do I think that this is spicy and
exciting for gma3 like it's something
for gma3 it's not the most like you know
ethical relationship
um but it's something and I think it's
exciting that they they seem happy and
in love and I hope they live happily
ever after that's the only way it works
it's the only way at this point like
this big circus will have been worth it
is if the two of them live happily ever
after but it seems like they both have a
problem keeping it in their pants so
even if this is a true love like this
will not be the end you don't just stop
cheating after cheating for a million
years but let me ask you something if
ABC is really so scruple that we have
taken off the air indefinitely like when
TJ was having an affair within a
producer he was which is definitely
crosses the line in terms of hierarchy
while he was more married than he is now
right but I just want to say like love
this wife love that she hired the pi and
then literally saw the pictures I'm sure
she had no idea anyone would care
because honestly like if we're being
honest with one another her husband
isn't nobody
um but you know it's it's just you never
know what's going to catch on she
thought that like it would get pressed
and the people you know media people
would care and it would be enough to do
something within the network but I don't
think she realized like how many lay
people would care right because like why
do I care I up until the other day I had
never heard of these people yeah
but it's sexy it's sounds like the
beginning of one of my books
Cabin in the Woods or the like 75 when
things start to go south yeah because
it's like nobody knows like they've you
know been in really unhappy marriages
and like it's totally fine they are in
love but like your book's like it starts
really good it's Peaks Peaks Peaks
there's a dip you know everyone finds
out their secret can they make it
through this then TJ has to go like
banging down her door being like it's
only been you like I don't and I'm sure
Amy didn't know about the producer maybe
and now she's finding out I'm not the
first one right she finds out with
everyone TJ doesn't know about Matt no
so true and so I think they both have to
forgive each other TJ didn't know about
Matt I'm like who's Matt not you being
on one name basis with Matt Lauer now
they have to forgive each other right
and learn to trust together right and
then for one last [ __ ] in your book for
one month and then you can pick up the
sequel right which is all about the Xbox
yes they find each other in times of
need yeah
well those were the past five and you
definitely needed to know every single
one of them but for me they were just a
means to an end you know a way to
finally start talking about Yellowstone
because not being able to talk about it
this whole time has been really hard
um so the Yellowstone chit chat it's not
really a recap it's like an update
debrief thank you is brought to you by
Skylight frames so the holidays are just
around the corner you should get a
skylight frame and put a picture of TJ
Maybe
other one if you're looking for a good
gift idea that your parents or in-laws
will genuinely love look no further than
the Skylight frame a photo frame you can
update instantly by email from anywhere
it's a great way to feel close to those
you love even when you're separated it
sets up effortlessly in under 60 seconds
just plug it in use the touchscreen to
connect to your Wi-Fi network and enjoy
sending photos to Skylight is effortless
everyone in the family can use the app
or just email them to a skylight then
they'll pop up in seconds and multiple
people can send photos to the frame so
it's a great way to keep large networks
of friends and families in touch it's
timeless it looks great it looks just
like a real photo frame it is the best
gift you can get to give to someone
um especially if it's like an older
person like an in-law a parent or a
grandparent because even if they're not
really tech savvy it is so easy to set
up it's like not something you need to
be um like Elon Musk to set up
um you know I've heard allegedly his
house is littered I've heard that too
I've heard like because there's so many
children that like is you know they're
always getting it for him as a gift
they're like dad we'll love this this is
what I look like now right um that's
what I've heard too so if it's good
enough for Elon it's pretty a legend
it's good enough for you as a special
offer you can get 15 off your purchase
of a skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com and enter code toast
so that's 15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com enter code toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com promo code
toast I had just had such a cute idea
because I've gotten Skylight frames for
other people but I think you and I
should get one for each other and update
and just like update it with like cute
pics of ourselves you know I'm gonna put
pictures of my boobs in it like yeah
I'll keep it like you might be private
yeah um but then like I'll send you like
cute pics of the day I think that's a
really cute way to keep in touch with a
friend moved yeah with a loved one who
abandoned you I agree yeah you did
abandon us and we're getting over it but
it's hard okay let me tell you about
Yellowstone so the part that I'm up to
right now is like you know the rainwater
Dan Jenkins and Kevin Costner have all
decided to get together because the back
Brothers have taken it too far too far
they beat up Beth that scene was so I I
could feel a shift like I knew something
like I knew something was going to
change between Beth and rip but like I
don't know like do they get together
like I feel like they don't and honestly
I'm just not interested in watching a
million more seasons of them like
[ __ ] around when the answer to
everyone's problem is them two getting
married and having children it's
literally so simple then Casey and his
like miserable family can go be
miserable somewhere else like they're
always upset and like people can't be we
couldn't be doing more for them like let
me give you my room let me give you the
shirt off my back this is not working
for me like it's always a problem
um
you know it was like insulting that they
tried to get her a job meanwhile she
took the job you know okay so I just
it's really a matter of who I hate the
least and it's Beth so I think right now
who I'm hating the most is that [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jamie like I could not believe he
killed that reporter like how dumb are
you like she's not like there's some
nobody in the from the middle of nowhere
she's from New York she works for a
[ __ ] magazine like you can't just
kill her because you're angry because
you were being dumb you didn't know what
to do oh my God like I just murder her
yeah like so dumb and he's like the
thing is me and Ben were discussing
because Ben's been watching with me we
can't tell if Jamie's the worst or he's
like he's actually a really bad actor
like the guy who plays him is like not
good
um
because like
like okay so he took a rifle and he was
like gonna kill himself and we were like
you're not gonna kill yourself and is
that just like him being a bad actor is
that Jamie like just being a drama queen
wanting attention it's Jamie okay
because he wasn't gonna kill himself no
even though like everyone was telling
him to him it's just like so [ __ ] up
like that's where Beth like I love Beth
but then when like she goes on her rants
against Jamie she says like the meanest
thing she's like
she said like an episode last night I'm
not just saying this because it would
bring me so much joy but you should
really consider killing yourself like
it's [ __ ] horrible like yeah she
really needs to stop like because that's
I love that she reads people to filth
even Jamie because he [ __ ] needs it
but like she takes it a little too far
um
so I definitely like Beth the most
then Casey and then Jamie I did like
Jamie at the beginning because you know
like he was a good lawyer yeah he got
them like much more land than they had
before he like they do need someone with
business smarts in the family yeah and
he was good at that job and he was like
everyone made fun of him because he was
like Posh and wore ties and like didn't
know how to shovel [ __ ] but it was a
vital part of the business
um he got obsessed with running for
attorney general and he like abandoned
his family and like you know what he
could have come back and it would have
been fine but he had to do the the
article like it was so he had to take it
so far like so dramatic For What and
that [ __ ] he was shacking up with like
she was horrible too like she was uh is
she the campaign yeah yeah she's
definitely not going away because they
just showed her again but like she was
really a problem
um
who else oh Jimmy
I love Jimmy like I don't know what the
point of like him being a main character
is because there's a million Cowboys and
a lot of them are better looking and
like we don't know anything about them
yeah but he's just when he won
um
the belt buckle because he needed that
money to pay back like his meth friends
and he won the Buckle and that guy the
older guy who has the brand what's his
name with the mustache
um
he's great Lloyd Lloyd and he had like
put the money up for him and he was so
proud and he was gonna cry like I was
not okay like it was so beautiful and
I'd love that he's like the that's what
the ranch is for like he really loves
the ranch now and like he was a bad kid
before
and then he had to sell his belt buckle
to the meth heads because that girl who
was working as a cowgirl who like ran
away in the middle of the night his
friend who he really liked
um
she owed them a thousand dollars like it
was so sad I was really upset when he
had to give away his belt buckle but you
know he he took care of it and he'll get
another one because he's really good at
riding the horses
um so there's just like a lot of
characters that I really like I
literally hate Thomas rainwater like I
hate the way he talks like first of all
Jacob's dad like I was shocked and yeah
I thought the first episode I'm like I
don't know if he's gonna be a main
character I didn't know like he would
really become like a huge part of the
show obsessed obsessed that it's Jacob's
dad but he's really so [ __ ] annoying
like always speaking slowly and giving a
sermon and it's just like stop yeah stop
no one's listening stop like really just
a few good lines he's got some good like
some words of wisdom okay but he's in no
rush I'm so glad you brought that up
because me and Ben have like stopped the
show like 10 times there's like Pearls
of Wisdom but it is I started watching
the show around the same time I started
reading and so many times I wanted to
like highlight I had the inkling to like
tap and highlight there's so many good
quotes and Pearls of Wisdom oh my god
when
you know uh Kevin Costner like was
playing with his grandson his grandson
fell in the river and it was really cold
and he was like I almost something bad
almost happened and then rip was like
well almost is interesting because it
doesn't [ __ ] matter and Kevin Costner
was like what idiot said that and he's
like uh you and it's true like almost
literally doesn't matter if something it
doesn't matter yeah so you're right I
wish I could highlight because it was
another one last night me and Ben were
like that's so true yeah like just
Pearls of Wisdom
um one good thing that like one Pearl
for Yellowstone that I got that I always
think about is like I think it was maybe
it was rainwater who said it that um
like you know how when right when you
give birth to a child the baby really
looks like the dad I saw that part yeah
he said like uh that is Nature's
paternity test and it's so true because
the baby like doesn't look like that for
even even one hour later but in that
moment you know who the father is so
true it's Nature's paternity test so
true
um so overall like this is just like
it's such a journey and I'm really
enjoying it like I want to be caught up
like I also want to enjoy it because you
know last night me and Ben were about to
start episode 9 of 10 on season two but
it was like 11 30 and I was like I have
a big day today so we didn't end up
watching it and like I actually really
do want to enjoy it but I also want to
be caught up because like I'm already
like five years too late she used to
watch like two episodes today no I don't
have time today I'm recording my special
I know but what do I have a few hours no
I have no time I have no time like well
you have a week to get caught up I guess
I will I will no it's a huge priority
for me especially because like this
weekend I will be doing nothing but
watching Yellowstone and then you can
watch 1883 I don't know and then you can
watch 1923. I know I have a few more
episodes of 1883 and I'm going to watch
them so that I can watch 1923 because it
looks amazing and so well cast Harrison
Ford Helen Mirren Michelle Randolph
run us over
um so thank you for the guidance on this
journey I'm sorry it took me so long to
get here I just wish I had a time
machine so that I could play this
episode for you
even a week ago when I said if you go to
Montana hey just watch Yellowstone
before
and I have jobs well I honestly thought
it was going to be like 20 episodes
every season it's only 10 like that's
normal
okay but that changes if it was 20 you
wouldn't watch it no and also the first
episode was um like a hundred minutes
and when I tell you it took me all
Saturday like I could not believe the
episode was never ending yeah
great some things are worth waiting for
no and I I agree and I'm glad I waited
and now you're like the foundations have
been layered and now you're really gonna
get into it like it gets it gets so good
yeah it keeps getting better yeah even
this season is so good yeah no I'm I'm
really enjoying it so thanks for the
recommendation girly you're welcome
you're welcome so that's our show that
is our show and you know it's time for
it to end because I have to pee so bad
okay well I'll wrap it up I'm excited to
see everyone tonight at my special
taping and tomorrow night but I'll see
you oh so a little programming update I
am here today and tomorrow and then
Wednesday I am going to take the day off
I just feel like I'll need you know like
a star moment like I will have recorded
my special I'll probably get drunk
afterwards like celeb's gonna celeb but
since Jax is in the city she's recording
with a sickening co-host it will be
Audio Only and you'll understand why
when the guest is announced yes and so
that's all we'll say about that but
looking forward to it thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available podcasting we're podcasting we
found out Spotify iTunes it's your
public video everybody gets back to all
the places in a podcast find us the
toast and leave a five-star review about
how
talented we are have an amazing day and
we'll see you tomorrow goodbye love you
bye